science and censorship are in fact  incompatible the reason is that the  scientific Enterprise  and makes progress and moves forward by  conjecture and refutation by generating  a hypothesis and doing a study to  potentially refute the hypothesis it has  to be an ongoing open conversation where  debate where novel perspectives were  challenges to Orthodoxy or conventional  thinking are not only permitted but  welcomed and then tested against the  empirical evidence that's how science  proceeds so trying to fixate whatever  the current consensus happens to be and  and lock it in in law is something that  cannot be challenged by physicians  will stifle the progress of science  [Music]